it's complicated and sad it's the middle
east is complicated enlarges earth hello
and welcome to trigonometry I'm Frances
Foster i'm konstantine Kissin and this
is a show for you if you're bored with
people arguing on the internet over
subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our brilliant guests this week is an
author filmmaker and co-host of the
conflicted podcast Thomas More welcome
to chicken AMA tree thanks for having me
nice to be here
[Music]
it's great to have you here tell
everybody who you are what's your story
how would you happen to be sitting in
the chair that you are in right now well
I don't know that you guys called me up
which I'm very pleased that you did
I'm Thomas small I am American
originally though I've lived in England
for about well in Europe for 19 years a
correct decision so yes so so America
seems like quite a long ways away Who am
I I left America as a young man and I
wanted to to be perfectly honest I
wanted to find God I wanted to become
one with God a very strange young man
kind of thing to want to do I ended up
spending several years in and out of
greek orthodox monasteries in the
eastern Mediterranean and thinking I'm
thinking of becoming a monk deciding not
to become a monk travelling more widely
around the Middle East deciding the
Middle East was an interesting place
went to university here in London to
study Arabic and then having spent a
year in Damascus learning that language
and then travelling more I became a
documentary filmmaker and I make films
in Arabic for four Arabs to watch and
you also have the conflicted podcast
which I introduced at the beginning
interesting I listened to the first five
minutes of the first episode I was like
okay this is going to be good you know
it does have that real capture feel to
it tell people a little bit about how it
happened what you do and how you met
your co-hosts and a bit about him as
well
conflicted which I host along with my
friend Eamonn Dean
is-is-is I think different I'm glad that
you you liked it as you did I mean Amon
is a fascinating person he is a Saudi
born guy at the age of 16 I think or
maybe 15 I can't remember he joined the
the jihad in Bosnia and became a
jihadist and then having wend his way
through when did his way through
different jihad fronts he ended up
joining al-qaeda in Afghanistan
swearing allegiance to Osama bin Laden
in person and then a year or so later
realized I don't really think we should
be slaughtering thousands of innocent
people so he left al-qaeda and joined
mi6 and became mi6 his top double agent
inside al-qaeda now I met him during
while I was working on a film called
path of blood a feature film that tells
the story of an al Qaeda campaign inside
Saudi Arabia I met up with him during
that period for research person purposes
and we immediately hit it off became
friends he is a font of amazing stories
as you can imagine with that biography
and his analytical powers especially
when it comes to Middle Eastern politics
and and ideological trends within the
Middle East are constantly fascinating
so we decided what we were approached by
a producer to do a podcast because you
know he thought we would have something
to offer and a bit like this show it's
quite conversational we're friends it's
not too antagonistic or a conference or
you know aggressive it's just two
friends talking about this extremely
complicated subject if you ever joined
the terrorist organization but I mean
you've got quite the backstory so you
you do documentary films in Arabic I
mean what how do the Middle East
perceive the West in particular America
at this moment and in terms of four
Ksenia non-trump and possibly the
embassy in israel Wow I mean the first
thing is is that people who have black
and white views on the Middle East are
are tend you know it tends to reveal
thereby that they don't know very much
so the Middle East is extremely enormous
it's extremely complicated so what the
Middle East thinks about America is
impossible to say what you're saying is
the question yeah yeah well it's not a
stupid question it's a common question
but you know the Middle East is is is is
diverse
you know Arabs are extremely diverse and
with the Middle East has more than just
Arabs there are occurs there are Turks
there are all sorts of people all sorts
of religions not just Muslims within
Islam there are so many different sects
so it's it's complicated I would say in
general I mean and and and my my sort of
exposure to the least Middle East tends
to come more at a higher political level
and mainly Gulf sort of centered because
that's where the money is that's where
actually more more more the power is and
certainly when it comes to the way the
Gulf perceives America they tend and
have always tended to perceive America
very positively because it is America is
a great ally of theirs they are a great
ally of America America's military
Umbra umbrella has always protected the
Gulf states from aggression during the
Cold War aggression from various Russian
kind of moves within the Middle East and
now in their minds from Iran which for
them is the greatest the greater threat
during the Obama period the gulf
relationship became quite strained with
America because Obama adopted a
different but a new foreign policy
pivoted towards Iran and wished to bring
Iran out from the cold in from the cold
and and and he negotiated the atomic
treaty you know the atomic bomb treaty
with them which Trump has recently
cancelled which and so now the go for
hat they're happier with Trump than they
were with Obama for sure the average
like middle Easterner on the ground
you know again you got a you could take
your pick
you have liberal Middle Easterners who
probably see America as a good dish
thing that in general you know inspires
them although they're probably annoyed
that like they invaded Iraq and and
contributed to the destruction of that
massive country to some extent you have
Islamist Middle Easterners who think
America is the Great Satan you have
everything in between now as it comes to
Israel the same thing applies in general
you know in general Muslims have in
general opposed the State of Israel and
oppose I anism
that was certainly the case in the high
water years of anti-israeli sentiment
70s 80s 90s sorry before you go and just
define Zionism for people because it's
an it's a word that gets thrown around a
lot I don't know what it means well I
mean I think it's the easiest ways to
say that Zionism is the is is it is
Israeli nationalism it's the idea the
political idea that the Jews deserve a
nation-state of their own and that that
nation-state should be in the Holy Land
Zion the mountain and all around which
Jerusalem was built and that is called
Zionism so it's just like any form of
nationalism it's just the Jewish form
now it's complicated because Jews are at
great diaspora as you know and and they
don't all live there and many of them
oppose the State of Israel and it's all
very complicated but I think that's what
Zionism is Jewish nationalism focused on
the Holy Land and Muslims have tended to
to oppose I oppose it in more recent
years because that has slightly changed
I think you know I don't know the Arab
in the street or the Muslim on the
street may feel the same way although I
think I get a sense that there's a kind
of Israel Palestine exhaustion you know
because the the conflict is intractable
it's going on forever and ever there
seems to be never any solution I think a
lot of people are just worn out a lot of
Muslims I should say a lot of Arabs just
kind of are sick of it
I think but certainly at the higher
levels there has been
a massive thawing in relations between
Arab governments and Israel because for
various reasons one it is that they feel
they have a common enemy in Iran so they
have knit themselves quite closely
together on the security front certainly
to combat that threat but and why this
fee overrun is it because what we hear
the Iran is trying to do well develop
nuclear weapons obviously there's a
there from a different faction of Islam
than the Gulf states right well yes
there are sheet Shia I mean the Iranians
are largely Shia
most Muslims particularly what's called
a Twelver Shia which is a subset within
the greater Shia and then on top of
their 12 or Shiism they have embraced or
has been imposed upon them what what we
might call home an ism named after the
Ayatollah Khomeini the
leading light of the 1979 Iranian
Revolution which fused Shia Iran a Shia
Iranian sort of religious ideas with
Bolshevik kind of revolutionary ideas
and millenarian apocalyptic ideas into
this new thing overthrew the Shah and
created this new state the Islamic
Republic of Iran in the Constitution of
which is a commitment to spread the
revolution beyond its borders now that
is obviously threatening in general that
you have a very powerful oil-rich state
with an enormous military that in its
constitution is has sworn to to sort of
destabilize topple and conquer other
states now whether they can actually do
it fine who knows but they are sworn to
do it and it's in their constitution so
for the last 40 years most of its
neighbors have been have felt threatened
it's because Iran is literally
threatening them at the same time for
all of that time Iran has sponsored
organized paid for an unbelievable
network of of non-state actors
throughout the region militias armies
jihadist groups most of them Shia not
all of them Shia because ultimately the
mullahs of Iran are happy to get into
bed with anyone that might destabilize
the nation states of the Arab world so
it's not like the question shouldn't
why why do they fear Iran the it should
be obvious Iranian proxies effectively
control Iraq through Shia militias that
are constantly destabilizing that
country they stay effectively control
Lebanon through Hezbollah which they pay
and for and run and you know the Hassan
Nasrallah the head of Hezbollah is open
open open agent of the Iranian state and
they basically have squeezed the
Lebanese government they you know there
are definitely underground cells of
Iranian activists funded activists and
militants throughout the Gulf states and
the Houthis in Yemen are certainly
Iranian allied and Hezbollah trained and
they have effectively conquered half of
Yemen and control the government
apparatus there so it's not why are they
afraid there is actually a campaign
right now by on by the Iranian state to
destabilize those countries the Iranians
would say oh this isn't offensive this
is defensive our network of militias and
they're very open about this there
especially opened these days I don't
know if you know that the last few
months there have been terrible floods
in Iran
terrible terrible floods thousands of
people have died really bad and for the
first time
Iran has actually flown in its militants
from its it's proxies elsewhere Afghan
jihadists who have been in in who were
Iran sent to the fields of Syria of
course they control Syria I forgot that
through Bashar al-assad they control
Syria so that's another big thing that
they now control and they they have
flown in these proxies from outside Iran
and they have ordered them to help with
the flood recovery effort and they've
they've very much sort of broadcast this
on the Iranian TV saying look these are
our friends either helping us they're
helping us save you from floods so
they're open about these proxies these
militant militants that they support and
I forgot I've lost my train of thought
well the question was about Iran and why
the conflict between them and other well
this that that's the answer it's a big
question so big it's a big it's a big
area no I know what I was saying so the
Iranians would say they're defending
themselves yeah so they stay they think
that you know the United States of
America and its allies which according
to Iranian sort of rhetoric is the Great
Satan it has it has its designs on Iran
and has always had its designs on Iran
and it's true that before the Iranian
Revolution during the period of the Shah
Iran was very closely integrated into
the global America American dominated
order well let's say the American side
of the Cold War in the Cold War and it's
true that certainly the CIA you know got
into various activities within Iran and
Iran ian's began to resent that fact and
so ever since the Revolution there has
been this idea that that we are under
threat from America we have to protect
ourselves so they would say these
proxies protect us they give us leverage
they know what they can say to America
you attack us and we will order our our
people to attack Beirut or attack Yemen
or attack Baghdad that's what they would
say I think that that's nonsense
I think that they actually because
that's what they open they'd be claimed
every Friday and their sermons they
actually wish to in some kind of
religiously inflected way conquer the
Holy Lands and Mecca and bring in the
end times and all this stuff I've got to
say of admire my restraint when you say
they funding terrorist cells of my own
mind and my tongue was like it's one of
them the Labour Party brought a question
about the Middle East because you know
as we were talking before we started my
question wasn't broad enough no when
when you start to study and understand
the attempt to understand this region
and you obviously understand it very
well you you say I think rightly that
everything becomes more complicated but
I almost feel like if you want to
understand why the Middle East is so
complicated you just have to look at the
map of it because of the straight lines
that you see everywhere and you go back
to the British and the French carving
these countries out of thin air creating
places like Syria where you've got all
kinds of different tribes living in one
country and almost like the only way to
control that kind of place is to be a
dictator like I said I'm saying
again an artificially created country or
a Bosch al-assad or or Gaddafi in Libya
like all of these places they're so
multi-ethnic and multi-religious and all
these groups have been fighting each
other for centuries is it inevitable
almost that you end up with these
strongmen dictators in all these places
because of the history of colonialism
and the legacy that we left again gosh
what a huge question I I think a lot of
my friend a lot of my middle-eastern
friends say that certainly they say you
know I mean I have an Egyptian friend
who when the Arab Spring happened which
then at first ushered in a Muslim
Brotherhood government which was seen as
threatening to some actors there and
other actors who then sponsored a coup
and returned a military dictator to
power I have an Egyptian friend who said
that's right that's what we need
Egyptians can only be governed with an
iron fist
an Iraqi friend says the same thing
about about Iraq the Iraqis have always
been dominated by a strong man's for
5000 years that's how it's run they need
one where you know we're crazy that's
what they say I I don't necessarily know
if it's inevitable that those polities
need to be run in an authoritarian way
it certainly is the case I mean I also
think that there's a there's a narrative
which says that the countries of the
Middle East were invented by by the
European colonial powers in an almost
arbitrary way this narrative is grossly
exaggerated it's it's not really true I
mean most of the those born you know if
you look at the infamous sykes-picot
agreement and the map that they kind of
drew it actually isn't equivalent to the
map as it exists in the Middle East
today people don't often recognize that
fact because you know and a lot of
historical research has proved beyond a
shadow of a doubt that that when the
Ottoman Empire which ruled over that
region for 400 years collapsed following
the first world war and there was a
great scramble by the colonial powers to
stamp their control over that region
they couldn't really just control it and
and there was an upswell from the ground
as you would imagine
as the imperial power retreats of
various attempts on their own on the
part of the local actors to gain control
you know various tribal alliances and
and movements and you know some ethnic
some religious and there was a great
scramble and in the end a lot of those
borders were determined by those actors
and their relationship with the new
colonial powers and and more or less the
borders correspond to Ottoman provinces
so I think too much is made of this as
if like the problems in the Middle East
are to do with the with the West just
kind of messing it up we played a role
there's no question we played a role but
what we're really seeing is the is the
after-effects of the collapse of a
massive Empire it's a hundred years ago
now that it happened but the
consequences are with us when a huge
centralised well-established efficiently
run for a lot of its history Empire
collapses what happens what kind what
kind of politics does that give rise to
what kind of leaders come to the come to
the fore you know in a case of the
Middle East military ones authoritarians
kings authoritarian kings absolute mana
you know so I guess my point was less
about blaming the West necessarily but
for example the Soviet Union collapsed
and because it contained within it
broadly speaking countries which were
consistent in terms of ethnicity in
terms of language etc so Lithuania and
Latvia and Estonia didn't need to have
you know a massive war any disputes
there were some conflicts and regionally
between different countries but broadly
speaking those countries kind of made
sense
where's Iraq for example you know you
have Sunnis Shia Kurds who all pretty
much have been fighting for a very long
time as you just explained with Iran
don't really get on very well Kurds want
their own country any like and you look
at almost any country in the region and
they have an element of that zero again
another example yeah the diversity I
mean I think again historically
especially during the Ottoman period the
Middle East was extremely peaceful
because the whole region was controlled
by two empires the Ottoman and the
Safavid and its successor empires in
Iran so two states control what are now
a myriad estates of states it was Europe
that was not peaceful during those
centuries Europeans were slaughtering
each other constantly
but the Middle East was stable so this
idea that like Shia and Sunni have been
fighting forever and Kurds are it's not
really true again it's not really true
it is the consequence of the collapse of
that impure of that arrangement and the
introduction into the region of
nationalism ethno-nationalism which
Europeans invented as a as a kind of
political principle into a into a region
the traditional governing structures of
which couldn't cope with it because it
was such a patchwork you know a Kurdish
village next to a Assyrian village next
to an Arab village that Shiite next to
an Arab village that's half Christian
half Sunni how do you and in a region
that has had for centuries a governing
philosophy based on your religion not
based on your ethnicity or your language
so how do you square that weird circle
well it causes conflict I mean that so
that I think is more it's a more recent
phenomenon than that idea like they've
been fighting each other forever it's
not really true
they haven't been fighting each other
forever these strong men dictators of
the of the Arab world of the Middle East
have tried to forge through violence
nation-states out of an incredible
patchwork of people who didn't feel
United based on nationality originally
they do now I mean that to some extent
that that effort succeeded in you know
Iraqis do feel Iraqi and Saudis do feel
Saudi and Egyptians certainly feel the
Egyptian but that just took well it took
the same amount of violence as it took
us in Europe we were very violent as we
were forging these new identities so
that's that side which explains if I
make kind of tent go on a tangent which
explains actually the appeal and the
rise of Islamism as a political
philosophy because these because these
people you know they actually had
thought of themselves first and foremost
as Muslims not as Kurds not as Iraqis
and not Assyrians so
much easier for a kind of political
philosophy that attempted to unite them
into one polity which you know that idea
underlies movements like the Muslim
Brotherhood and whatever that's why that
that has so much appeal it appeals
instinctively because they have that
identity whereas any plan I get in the
Christian world a philosophy that was
predicated on the fact that we're all
Christians wouldn't get off the ground
because actually if the people of the
West are majority Christian but it
doesn't actually anchor our identity
well we don't have a history of the
Caliphate well we don't have what we but
we don't have a history of the Caliphate
what we did have a history of a great
Christian Imperium which then came
unstuck in the 16th century and then
then evolved into nation-states which
then fought each other brutally which
then has given rise to movements of
transnational movements like the EU and
like the United Nations you know so we
you know these again I'm giving a very
complex answer to this huge question
yeah and I hope that it's not too
confusing it's very current and very
interesting why why is it the oh this is
gonna be another broad question we
always see you know America getting
involved Britain getting involved and
then it never seems to end well and then
you always get people majority of them
on the left go and the only reason
they're getting involved is because of
oil all the rest of it how much of this
is the West getting involved in these
countries because you know they want it
to be stable they want them to live
under a democracy they want freedom of
law all the rest of it and how much of
it is because of oil or other nefarious
activities
I couldn't quantify it it's a mixture
and it's a very uncomfortable mixture I
mean a recent report came out I can't
remember what but I found it very
interesting which basically proves by
marshalling a whole amount of evidence
that the Iraq war of 2003 for example
was not about oil this is a great a
great myth the oil companies
particularly American oil companies
utterly opposed the invasion of Iraq
they totally opposed it it was not in
their interests whatsoever
and the neo-cons that informed the
ideology of george w bush didn't care
they actually were obsessed with the
idea of bringing democracy to the middle
east i think they were ideologically
committed neo conservative hyper liberal
liberals and i actually thought that in
some kind of like but through some magic
that base i think they think that the
natural state of mankind is democratic
liberalism a lot of people forget this
that democratic liberalism is a highly
evolved highly complex manufactured form
of of social governance it's not natural
at all it is highly unnatural but they
sort of thought that they thought you
lob a grenade into the middle of the
Middle East and you topple the dictators
end and democracy will flourish they
they believe that so that that was
really what that was about the the oil
companies the American oil companies
opposed it and following the war the
American oil companies have not profited
from it the oil contracts that the the
you know the the independent Iraqi
government largely you know influence
now by Iran ironically have awarded the
oil contracts they've awarded have not
gone to American companies that's true
actually we had Chinese another we had
to form a presidential advisor on the
show and she didn't we didn't talk with
her about this but that was one I kept
badgering her in the pub about this and
go yeah but wasn't about oil and she was
going well actually American companies
didn't get any of the oil contracts for
the actual oil they got like Halliburton
got some like so at the beginning and
Halliburton got some yes right but it
wasn't that big but there are other
areas of it like the Gulf yeah the Gulf
originally was important
geo-strategically in the British
Imperial period because of weigh
stations along the route to India so it
was basically the Gulf has is
geo-strategically important just because
of its location it just along these
incredibly important water is the Red
Sea the Suez Canal the Strait of Hormuz
on the on the way into the Indian Ocean
so it would be an important place anyway
for any global
order that sought to maintain free
market free open trade routes because
it's so important the discovery of the
world's largest oil gas supplies
increased that had importance enormously
and so yes to some large extent the the
Middle East the actual Gulf you know the
heart of the Arabia itself is important
because of oil and that remained that is
and the thing is is that simply so I
mean there's a kind of paranoid
conspiracy perspective that would say
that would say that you know we only get
involved in the Middle East because of
oil as if that's an option you know
people don't quite understand how
important oil is to the functioning of
the entire world now the oil price the
price of oil underpins basically the
price of everything because oil fuels
this incredibly amazingly powerful and
productive global economy everything
depends on the price of oil the price of
oil quintupled overnight the global
order would just kind of collapse
because everything would get so
expensive to produce no one could afford
it it caused massive inflation price
inflation you know so it's not arbitrary
there's no choice but to care about oil
and to make sure that it is stable that
the price is clear that the price you
know reflects more or less market
conditions people who think that you
could just kind of wash your hands of
caring about that problems they don't
understand how important it is
is this another great answer because I
never really thought of it like that I
never thought that actually of course
everything is dependent on all therefore
what they therefore it makes complete
sense for them to be involved well half
the stuff you're wearing now it's made
of oil thanks mate no no I'm serious
yeah yeah plastic most of your shoes
made people don't understand what how
the importance of petroleum as a product
I think they think of it as like it's in
cars they just think well we drive we'll
just drive less or something they don't
understand that as a product petroleum
now you can be some kind of you know
Luddite or some kind of you know
romantic pastoralist or something you
know in fact there's a part of my soul
that is if I wanted to live I wanted to
be a monk at one point so I'm not wholly
invested in you know
ever in consumerism and stuff if that's
what you want great but in fact nothing
is preventing you from living that life
but if you think that the world is going
to embrace that then you're just fooling
yourself people actually don't want to
go back to subsistence farming and so
looking at the Middle East was Trump's
impact bin because a lot of people go
you know he's a racist he's a bigot he
does this he does that he's you know and
then you know over the year the embassy
and now in Jerusalem it's an
inflammatory gesture but what actually
has been his impact well I mean I
mentioned his impact in the Gulf the
Gulf states were pleased to see the end
of Obama yeah they think the Trump is a
man they can they can work with better
to counter Iran and that seems to be
happening and as we record this because
there's this great you know sense that
is there gonna be a war in fact I mean
Trump has said he said last night I
don't want war with Iran who knows the
Israel question is interesting I mean I
don't know Trump I would not hit I
didn't vote you know cuz I've lived here
for a long time and I don't really think
of my I don't really think I should vote
because I'm Russian I but I wouldn't
have voted for Trump I don't understand
his psychology I don't pretend to I
think he does seem to have this kind of
bullish realism about in his approach to
things unlike George W Bush who was a
neocon or at least influenced by
neo-cons which is an ideologically
idealistic point of view democracy will
spread you know through the military
means he's not like Obama who was also
an idealist but more of a kind of
neoliberal academic central leftist type
that you know if we just hold hands and
wish very hard everyone will be nice to
each other including Iranian mullahs
hell bent on the destruction of the
Israeli state so Trump is more like well
is the truce is
is Jerusalem effectively the capital of
Israel yes has it been so for over 40
years yes then it is so you know he he
doesn't necessarily have the nuanced
appreciation of what that means but it
sounds like recently with what by he by
his ratifying Israeli occupation of the
Golan Heights you know they run the
Golan Heights for decades so he's just
says let's get over it and move on they
but they you know Israel runs it I think
that's really what he he is he's doing
he called the bluff of the of the more
liberal you know establishment say or
foreign policy establishment because the
blowback for these moves has been very
minor Netanyahu was reelected to run
Israel the Arab states remain ever
closer allied with that government to
counter Iranian influence Arabs on the
street didn't rise up in great
tremendous protests you know there's a
Hamas and Israel fight and they have
been fighting recently and that will
continue so in a way it's a fait
accompli just happened and because it's
just recognizing facts on the ground it
seems to me so it's essentially a more
pragmatic approach and more world
realistic approach it seems to be a more
realistic approach I mean it is filtered
through a psychology of great great
wonderment to the average of you know
Twitter viewer but there there does seem
to be something like a realist position
in forming it and what why is it that
the left aligns itself so strongly with
the Palestinian cause
well they didn't always of course which
is interesting
Zionism was originally quite left
inflected and it was a nationalist
movement which we think of as a right
wing thing but Zionists themselves the
leading lights of Zionism who tended to
be well a lot a larger proportion of
them tended to be kind of upper-middle
class educated Europeans they tended to
be liberal ly inclined and slightly even
more like radically inclined the kibbutz
movement was communitarian and Zionism
was seen as
kind of utopian left-leaning movement
that changed in with time as it was as
the situation was reinterpreted that
were Israel was seen as a colonialist
movement of foreign aggression sponsored
by the Great Satan era so you know in a
Cold War context America is the enemy of
the left supports the right so you can
see then why the friend of Israel
America being on the right means that
the enemy of Israel the Palestinians is
on the left so left-wing people support
them you know you have someone like
Jeremy Corbyn a person like that who
like Noam Chomsky you know for him
slightly paranoid in a paranoid way he
sees America as effectively an evil act
or on the world stage and anything
resisting anything to do with America
must thereby be good which is why you
know he has tended to us be vocal in
support of Iran and Venezuela and such
in Cuba and places like that that
position themselves as opposed to the
American Empire great places to live so
you know but and also you know it is
true that the Palestinians have been
given something like a raw deal by
history by the Israeli government and by
Israelis and by the reitman by their
fellow Arabs actually who have not done
them any favors I think Palestinians
haven't done themselves so many favors
it's a pity I think that they first
tended to throw their their longing for
prosperity and dignity into that with
the PLO which was a very left-wing
Bolshevik kind of inspired movement led
by Yasser Arafat of course and then more
recently Hamas which is a Muslim
Brotherhood Islamist movement and that
hasn't served much purpose for the poor
Palestinians who just exist unhappily in
their in their somewhat degraded State I
mean I haven't been to to Palestine for
a long time so I don't actually know
what it is like on the ground when I did
visit it you know they were building the
wall there and I had friends in in
Bethlehem
will Beit Jala in fact a Christian
Palestinian family I went and stayed
with and you know it was pretty
depressing you know you could look down
at this wall and and you know clearly
the economic differential between
themselves and what they saw on the
other side of the wall was vast but then
at the same time you know suicide
bombers and lobbing rock rockets and you
know to some extent the Palestinian
cause embraced violence as its as its
means of achieving its objectives and
when you embrace violence against a far
greater enemy you know you're gonna lose
so they might think of adopting other
approaches it's easy for me to say that
I've often wondered like imagine if a
kind of Palestinian Gandhi could arise
and and and employed pacifist means for
achieving those ends who knows what
would happen would it would it to some
extent neutralize the power of Israeli
aggression to get its aims and would it
who knows but that that kind of a figure
hasn't really arisen what I find
interesting about how how that the
issues in relation to your question is
you'd in the West is you get people who
clearly know nothing about the issue
someone like Alexandra or Kaiser
quarters and one of her first interviews
that she did after after being elected
she was asked about Israel and Palestine
and why she supports Palestine and it
was transparent for all to see that she
had no idea what she was talking about
that's all she knew nothing about it and
yet she was vehemently pro-palestinian
and it seems to me like it's become an
issue almost like you know these big
American political issues are you pro
gun control or against guns are you
pro-abortion or against them and what
you think about it is determined not so
much about what the facts are but which
party you're in it's it's a flag-waving
exercise and i think i mean i'm i am not
an expert on the israeli-palestinian
issue by any means but it's I think I
know enough not to really stand up and
wave the flag for either side it's an
incredibly complicated ultimately quite
tragic situation of a conflict of
interests and a conflict of power aims
and a conflict of nationalisms and
religions and you know it's extremely
complicated someone who just says you
know the Palestinians are only victims
and the Israelis are only evil are as
stupid as a as a really really really
radical Zionist who would basically say
the Palestinians are all terrorists and
they never even lived in this land until
the nineteen tens and you know etc so I
think you just have to it's complicated
and sad it's the Middle East is
complicated and largely said guys we
wanted to tell you we're very excited to
say we've got a new sponsor which is
hello fresh indeed we have hello fresh
is a UK's leading recipe box service
delivering fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and step-by-step recipes to
your door it is the easy convenient way
to cook delicious dinners from scratch
every single time choose your favorites
from 19 recipes every week they have a
whole range of options there for you
including recipes that are ready in
under 20 minutes there's family
favorites there's British cuisine
there's world cuisine there's even a
five hundred and fifty calories on the
range and that's a great thing because
as you may have noticed in the time that
we've been doing the show Francis has
actually lost quite a bit of weight so
congratulations to him on going from
being massively fat to just being really
fat that's great and if you want to
achieve the same results as Francis keep
eating lard but if you want to be
healthy and slim like me
check out these extra healthy recipes
from hellofresh hellofresh we're
offering trigonometry fans 60 pounds off
four boxes to take advantage of that go
to hello fresh coda UK enter our special
code which is of course trigonometry and
enjoy delicious dinners without any of
the drama the fresh ingredients come
direct from suppliers ie
they've been picked by Constantine's
family you can tell Francis studied
geography at a British School because he
can't tell the difference between Russia
and Romania doesn't matter mate same
thing breaks it means breaks it and the
great thing is it's been proportioned
for you so there's no food waste
just like in my home country of
Venezuela the great thing we've had
fresh is that you're gonna be able to
choose from
nineteen different recipes every week so
there is something for everybody
you're going to be able to eat with you
kids it's gonna be no fuss dinnertime
it's gonna be solved yeah I really like
the rapid box which allows you to cook
things in under under 20 minutes but the
great thing about hellofresh as well is
it actually allows you to open up your
cooking range so most households on
average have about six recipes that they
cook regularly hellofresh has up to 19
so you can kind of expand a little bit
in terms of your cooking and of course
they also don't have a fixed
subscription so there's no term you can
cancel you can skip weeks you can change
the size of the box you can change the
livery address you can do all kinds of
stuff to suit your life to enjoy
delicious moments head over to
hellofresh code UK choose your box
choose your delivery slot and add your
favorite recipes discover the easy way
to get delicious dinners from scratch
and if you do that you'll get sick abs
just like me hello fresh we're offering
trigonometry fans 60 pounds off four
boxes to take advantage of that go to
hello fresh coda UK enter our special
code which is of course trigonometry and
enjoy delicious dinners without any of
the drama
[Music]
speaking of conflicts probably the
biggest conflict recently and also in
terms of the impact on the West the
conflict probably that is driving many
of the political shifts and problems and
challenges and transformations and also
maybe opportunities that we see now in
the West with nationalism and all of
this kind of stuff a lot of it seems to
be linked to the conflict in Syria and
then the ensuing refugee crisis and and
it's like one big snowball it's that's
happened so in five minutes I mean not
in five minutes or less but just explain
for anyone who doesn't understand or
know much about it how has that happened
what has happened was it the the
collapse of Iraq and the emergence of
Isis there that then spread into Syria
is that really a stupid question you
look at me like it is no no that's not
stupid but I mean it's not accurate it's
not a stupid question no I lived in
Syria for in 2007-2008 and in that year
none of us who were living there would
have thought that that this was that the
country was going to become the Byward
first national collapse in civil war
death it didn't seem like that was on
the cards four years later it began you
know originally the the Arab the the
episode I think it's the fifth or fourth
fifth episode of our podcast conflicted
deals with the Syrian civil war and Amon
had a lot of interesting things to say
about it that I didn't know one of the
things he said which is that the
protests that broke out in Syria during
the beginning of the Arab Spring you
know which was this much this
region-wide
uprising movement the protests in Syria
focused very clearly on essentially on
police brutality in that in that country
it was it had become de rigueur for the
police within Syria to kidnap young 11
12 year old boys raped them and deposit
them in dumpsters as a way of scaring
local populations into behaving and
that's terrible and so they they were
rallying something like that happened in
a southern town they rally they
empowered I guess or inspired by the
Arab Spring they rose up and said well
we actually would like this to stop they
petitioned the President Bashar al-assad
whom they had no interest in toppling
you know come on stop just stop this you
know bring the police under control
instead of doing that he ordered or
allowed the police to fire on the crowds
and then it just became then it became a
violent uprising Syria is is extremely
important geographically it's right
there in the middle borders Turkey which
is a very strong NATO state which had
for 400 years ruled Syria of course it
borders you know Jordan which is a
linchpin in the American security
apparatus the Jordanian Secret sort of
CIA effectively is one of the world's
best and mo
important in in combating Islamic
terrorism at borders Israel we know what
that means and that borders Lebanon
largely a failed state for 35 years so
you know it's very and and Iraq which by
that point was kind of a failed state as
well so it's very important the this and
it Syria also has the misfortune of
being a place where a lot of apocalyptic
stories that that Muslims and Islamists
especially tell themselves about the end
of days lots of villages are meant to
play key roles in the story that brings
the return of Jesus and and and and the
judgment of the world and they assure
again of the you know that the end times
sadly Syria is like the battleground for
that in Muslim eschatology so when a
civil war broke out there it was a lot
of you know radical Islamist extremist
jihadists thought the prophecies are
coming true you see you know it's all
happening in Syria so they kind of piled
in hoping to lure the west into
intervening because that's all part of
the end of times scenario I mean in in
the scenarios it's the Roman Empire
which intervenes and they think that the
Roman Empire just stands for the West
now so they were trying to lure the West
in because they thought that if they
could do that then the end of times
would happen and and they believed the
end of times will result in their in
their favor so Syria was to some extent
like a sacrificed on that on the altar
of those sorts of religious ideas which
is why there were so many Islamist
groups Iran Iranian Islamist actors got
involved because they Iran has the same
eschatological sort of ideas as the
Sunnis that they then started to fight
it became a total mess and then you know
Turkey got involved obviously because
the Kurds were involved in the turkey
has Kurds and they don't want the Kurds
to rebel in Turkey and then and then
then because of the Tartu Snavely base
Russia got involved and then Obama
didn't didn't actually respect the red
lines he'd drawn so Russia realized oh
we can just actually actually fight a
war here so they were throwing barrel
bombs and bomb
neighborhoods in America wasn't doing
anything and then Isis rose yeah so as a
result of which there was tremendous
migration away from Syria because who
would you know want to live that
terrible and you know a lot of that
migration went into Turkey which you
know and then the UN and other
institutions set up refugee camps but
then and a lot of those migrants wanted
to get in get to Europe for for safety
reasons and also like many migrants from
everywhere for economic reasons and that
became that trickle became a flood I
mean I think there was some bad there
was some manipulation by the Turkish
government they were letting a lot of
migrants in it was - they weren't
policing migration because they wanted
to use it as a bargaining chip with
particularly the Germans but EU in
general for various concessions which
they received which is why then they
stopped letting the migrants through so
it all became a mess and that famously
angular Merkel kind of said come come
come and then like 2 million over a
course of a summer came and that freaked
out the Hungarians and absolutely you
know they do the poor Greeks were
already on their knees they worse they
couldn't cope with all of these migrants
and their challenge and of course it had
a big impact even in this country I mean
even the BRICS referendum yeah it was
affected by people's concerns that's
right in some you know when 2 million
people come as much compassion as you
want to have that's going to have an
impact on the society and there's no
there's no getting away from that which
is why I say it's had a huge impact here
in the West as well as in Syria let me
ask another incorrect and stupid
question I've got a whole barrel room I
feel like my sense is the the reason
someone like bash al Assad doesn't want
to go didn't want to go when he when he
may have been time there was no one's
calling for that anymore but there was a
time when they were is that I'm thinking
if I were him right because this guy as
far as I know his background he's not
some you know evil religious fanatic who
spent his childhood slitting
Rhodes for entertainment he's an
ophthalmologist she's not an
ophthalmologist they're not all evil
yeah yeah so he was educated in the UK
as far as I know right
he went to ophthalmology school in the
UK yeah and he wasn't supposed to be
President his brother was his older
brother his brother died in like a car
crash or a plane something and then he
suddenly found himself having to do this
so as far as I see he doesn't strike me
as this kind of just evil person who's
just born evil and continues to be able
to ride the life for no reason right so
but I put myself in his position and I
go well what happened to the other
people who went or who gave up or who
tried to work with the West or who who
didn't try and fight if you like sad I'm
saying right his sons brutally murdered
in the street he himself hanged right
Colonel Gaddafi gave up his mass weapons
of mass destruction program because he
was promised - sure he was given
assurances by the West you're not him
for a change so I'm I'm preparing my
he's just going stupid stupid stupid so
here's a guy who looks around and he
goes well anyone who's tried to work
with the West or who hasn't
full-heartedly opposed to West right
ends up dead the Colonel Gaddafi was
given these assurances the West pulled
back bombed I think as far the either
bombed this convoy or let the rebels
know where his convoy was going rather I
don't know that that's the case I don't
think so I think so
rebels show up beat him up rape him with
a bayonet I know that right so if that's
your your situation and you know what's
gonna happen to you and your family and
your wife and your children yeah gasps
whatever whoever needs to be gassed as
most people that would be their reaction
you know what I'm saying
I do I mean I'm not sure if the if the
comparisons are entire
I mean Saddam Hussein didn't work with
the West and so he got it in the end
Gadhafi I mean okay to some extent the
West this betrayed him I mean I don't
feel any sympathy for I'm also he's a
great guy like Ben Ali of Tunisia who
left you know I now lives in Saudi
Arabia I think in some comfort I think I
think that's he certainly went to Saudi
Arabia initially in Lindner so it's you
know I think there were other things on
the table Bashar al-assad might have
made arrangements to live in a one of
Putin's magnificent palaces in Russia
for example maybe they would have
offered him safe haven and protected him
from or Iran you know might they could
share a mansion with Edward Snowden yes
exactly
so I mean Bashar al-assad I don't
understand his psychology I think when
evil is he evil and his father was a
tough bastard and a really wily one I
think that there was probably something
amounting to psychological abuse in his
childhood but being raised by that kind
of a person and I think it's pretty
clear that when it became clear that he
was going to be the president when it
wasn't expected before his father his
brother as you said was going to be I
think he was you know he was immediately
put through rigorous dictator training
which I which you know people have said
really changed him I mean and also you
have to see him in the Syrian regime is
like a it's really like a mafia
arrangement so Bashar al-assad is a bit
like Michael Corleone in The Godfather
you know he didn't he also wasn't meant
to take over the family business but
then Sonny was killed in the and he he
tried to get out but he just couldn't he
had to be and said you know he just
becomes this great mobster and has to
shoot his own brother at the end of
Godfather 2 and then he dies alone after
his daughter's killed Godfather 3 the
difference is Michael Corleone E is a
sympathetic character because he
actually wants to get out I don't think
there is any indication whatsoever that
Bashar al-assad wants to get out thinks
that he's done anything wrong
I think he thinks with some
justification I mean I can see his point
of view that he saved Syria from
Islamists from radical Sunni Isis style
Islamists he believed he did that I
suppose to some extent he did do that in
the meantime he destroyed the country so
so so yeah I think I guess what I'm
saying it was never did he have a choice
because if he left he probably would
have been killed is what I'm saying it
depends I mean those people Gaddafi
didn't leave Gaddafi stayed he resisted
the rebels he was caught he was raped to
death Saddam Hussein didn't leave he hid
he was found by the rebels he was hanged
so Bashar al-assad didn't even attempt
to negotiate some kind of some kind of
deal with the globe that's that's what
the UN say to get out it could have been
handled there's no question that it
could have been handled as I say Ben Ali
of Tunisia now lives in in Saudi Arabia
and no one's calling for him to go to
the Hague for it to stand for any kind
of crime so I don't think it's it's
about that really and in earlier in the
Nadi's bashar lacet did actually kind of
come in from the cold with the west and
formed suddenly this it was called the
Damascus spring it lasted from 2000 but
the year that he became president to
about 2003 for and he did suddenly seem
like he was going to be different from
his father and he was gonna you know be
warmer to the west and integrated into
the global order better but then when
the Iraq war happened he fearing he was
maybe next turned away from the West
again allied close more closely again
with Iran and also contributed vastly to
the destabilization of Iraq by allowing
Sunni jihadists out of Damascus prisons
actually in sending them into Iraq to to
cause havoc there so you know he he was
not a great guy no well certainly not
every guy I was just thinking of that
when you were talking about the
Godfather we're gonna need a warning is
gonna be spoilers for the Godfather
controversial podcast if you could do it
with game affront and introduce some
spoilers in just to piss up some people
well actually I was gonna ask you what
do you watch chemistry no I don't act I
told a friend yesterday I said I don't
watch Game of Thrones I work closely
with the Gulf states and and it says
that it's a real game of Thrones so what
is the state what is the state of the
caliphate at the moment does it still
exist what is happening around their
area well I mean Isis yes it doesn't
exist so much I mean it doesn't really
exist as a as a state anymore
I mean it's it's been deprived of its
geographical possessions it certainly
exists as a movement it and there are
still fighters and terrorists who are
causing problems in that area and it
continues to inspire jihadists and and
radical Islamists elsewhere whether it
coordinates with them directly or not I
don't know people don't necessarily know
but certainly it inspires and in the
name of Isis things continue to happen
so yeah you know I
the phenomenon of radical jihadism
remains it's not going away
but even though do you think the state
doesn't exist anymore
and and it's been defeated yes I believe
that to be the case I mean I when when
as a state defeated I mean I you know
that Michaela Baghdadi's still alive
he's still around he released a video of
last week I think for the first time in
several years announcing the fact that
you know the cause goes on so does it
exist does it not exist I mean it
doesn't it doesn't control it doesn't
militarily control anything like the
kind of territory that it did in the
territory that it may control would be
more like rural territory based on like
warlordism old school kind of control
which would ebb and flow but not like an
actual state apparatus anymore I think
why was I so so successful why was Isis
so successful
well the Syrian civil war
it basically caused a vacuum of power to
open up in the you know the eastern so
the eastern Syrian desert blends into
the Western Iraqi desert before recent
times that zone was kind of open and was
part of a wider Arabian desert zone
where all the tribes would you know the
Bedouin tribes would move quite freely
it's only in recent years as nations the
nation-state model has been imposed on
those areas that anything like a
difference has opened up but the
collapse of the Saddam Hussein regime
and then the collapse of full control by
the Bashar al-assad regime over Syria
reopened that zone and it's interesting
that that that zone is basically the
zone that became fell under the control
of Isis which was a Sunni Arab movement
that you that was closely United with
the local tribal Sunni warlord sort of
actors they bought off their allegiance
I think to some extent to the extent
that they were successful and getting
extremely rich because they had taxation
and they you know they they it was a
very rich movement they were able to
maintain the loyalty of those of those
more local kind of actors but the short
answer they were successful because of
the conditions of the collapse of Syria
gave a jihadist group an opportunity to
control and in fact it had happened
before them in Yemen when after the Arab
Spring there caused destabilization of
the previous regime and prevented the
capital Sana'a from projecting its power
adequately across the whole country even
though it had never really controlled
the whole country directly because it's
such a chaotic country al Qaeda in the
Arabian Peninsula which was based in the
had remote area which is which is on
this sort of east side of of Yemen was
able to effectively control a huge
amount of that country in erect state
like structures and stuff so that had
already happened so you know when the
nation-state crumbles
in the middle-east Islamist actors tend
to to become empowered which is why
someone like Ayman and I would agree
with him I know my co-host unconflicted
would say above all we must support the
nation states of the Middle East we
mustn't allow movements to destabilize
those nation states even if that means
in the short term putting up with
illiberal governments that's what he
would say and that was the common the
common understanding you know it's the
old school kind of Henry Kissinger style
rail politic understanding you must deal
you must support stability above all and
if that means you have to get into bed
with some [ __ ] well then you got to
get into bed with some [ __ ] and so
the one question that I really wanted to
ask before this interview was always why
is it and I know it's a really difficult
question to answer almost impossible but
why are they so effective at recruiting
people from the West because you you
know the Isis you think why would
anybody want to go to Syria or the
Caliphate you know what is the
attraction well I think grab use sorry I
think that question is just a sub set of
I mean I said it's it's falls within a
wider question of why is it wide are
they successfully recruiting so many
people yeah I mean recruiting so many
Muslims you know they recruit people in
the West because we have a lot of
Muslims in the West and a tiny tiny
minority of Muslims but enough to cause
problems in Syria were attracted to the
message of Isis why you know so it is
really hard to understand I don't
understand why anyone was ever attracted
to bolshevik you know terrorist cells I
don't understand that either I'm not a
radical I do not seek to kill people in
pursuit of some utopian aim and I do not
certainly do not seek to kill myself in
that aim I don't you know I don't
understand it
Isis tends to attract or I mean jihadist
groups tend to attract a wide range of
people they
kind of fall into two basic camps you
have an underclass kind of person who
you know let's say always a Muslim
obviously because it's a Muslim movement
so an Islamic movement so an underclass
Muslim who is maybe maybe was involved
in criminality of some kind you know
drugs like all forms of criminality
actually drugs tend to play a role they
yet they're Muslims so they may seek
some sense they want they want to redeem
their redeem themselves from their sin
and jihadist groups say come blow
yourself up or fight the jihad with us
and your sins are forgiven so that may
be very appealing to a set some people I
mean it also just appeals to sadists
they exist there are sadists everywhere
and there are Muslims sadists and if you
tell someone oh you're a sadist and in
the West they police sadism why don't
you come here we're not policing say to
them at all we're a Power you can chop
off heads and kill people and
discriminately you know that's appealing
to a sadist then you know there's
another group which is more middle-class
more educated because a lot of engineer
I'm at the higher levels of these
terrorist groups there are a lot of like
engineers and mathematicians because you
know who's making the bombs he's
complicated it's complicated to make a
to make a bomb so it appeals to that
kind of a person why they're more I
think ideologically committed they've
just they just believe in the worldview
that the Islamists peddle which is you
know kind of like it's like a paranoid
conspiratorial revolutionary worldview
it is not a million miles away from a
left of a radical left-wing worldview
the kind of people who were like blowing
themselves up and killing bizarre and in
the run-up to the Russian Revolution and
and people who were resisting the Nazis
and you know these two sides were
fighting it's kind of they've just got
him radical I don't understand I really
I to the state I just don't understand
why why people do it see the question I
think most people in this country would
want to know is why is it happening here
like what do they want like if if if
there was a button that we could press
that did something so that
would start blowing themselves up and on
the streets of Britain what would that
button what would the label next to that
button be is it leave Iraq is it
withdraw American bases from Saudi
Arabia what is it that there aren't any
of them so by the way but that's what
people say right yeah you hear that's
why I'm repeating it so what is it that
they want they I mean Isis wants this
Isis wants to lure the west into an
almighty battle in the Middle East
because they believe that if they do
that it will trigger an end of time
scenario where holy kind of do you know
spiritual warriors will come down from
heaven and vanquish the enemy so that's
what they want
good plan I mean they're they're they
are you know they're crazy they really
are crazy you know if you just read
there they believe this so they're poke
you know I think I think if I had to
understand their strategy if they just
can convince enough Western fellow
travelers to to blow themselves up at
pop concerts in Manchester or suddenly
go on the rampage with knives and kill
people in London Bridge or shoot up
shoot up a nightclub in Paris or let him
slice the necks of a priest in Paris in
France while he's so if they can just
poke the bear enough maybe he'll come in
and and and fight it's hard for us to
understand that like a lot of people
think that they want America out of the
Middle East and they sort of say this
it's part of their rhetoric I think it's
a because that's how they attract
recruits guys if they're there they
position themselves as freedom fighters
we want America out but it's not true
they actually want America in because
they think if America comes in then the
end of times will happen I think that's
my own raising that is absolutely well I
mean you have to be crazy to do these
people are crazy I mean but also a
hundred years ago there were
organize networks of radical Marxist
Bolshevik terrorists everywhere who
thought somehow through acts of violence
all of the working class ever would rise
up slaughter the bourgeoisie and utopia
would emerge that they're all so stupid
yeah but that was different because they
so in Russia for example they had a very
concrete plan for what they wanted to do
right they wanted to overthrow the
people who were oppressing them st. Leo
would they they would say were
oppressing the working class and make
everybody equal and you know someone
comes from Russia everybody was equally
poor right will you achieve that but
this is just religious like bad [ __ ]
mental stiii myself I don't I I think
that radical leftist utopian activism is
equally religious in most ways I mean
it's just it's materialist it doesn't
have a supernatural dimension but it's
equally predicated on crazy ideas fair
enough so I mean an Isis had it has like
a governing it can be what does it want
to do in in terms of governance well we
saw yeah you know the erect an extremely
draconian form of Sharia law over people
while kind of running a mafia style
operation that fleeces people of their
wealth in order to fund their it's not
actually so different from the
Bolsheviks to be honest they were all
equal to so let me just finish this line
of questioning Francis and at times
almost up
what you're saying then is that the only
way that we can release well as I
understand it based on what you've said
it's not what you're saying but based on
what you've said the only way we can
stop terrorism in the West is just a
security it's a security issue in other
words we have to catch these people
before they do this no that's not what
I'm saying I didn't know I I I don't
know how to stop terrorism in the West I
don't know I it's I know that it would
be very hard to completely stop it I
think in general in the West we are very
safe and that there isn't actually that
much terrorism and that we the West
especially this country have gone
through periods
as gone through periods of more
terrorism I mean the IRA was more
successful at killing more people more
frequently than Muslim terrorists have
been here really said to call you up
before so how do you but had it so I
mean I think that I think that along
with my friend Eamonn you know the
co-host of this podcast he who is Muslim
and he a pious Muslim you know he
believes that for this phenomenon to
stop Muslims themselves like him who
believe that the Islamist inflected
ideologies are not only bad in general
but also wrong interpretations of Islam
have to preach against them and have to
create you know networks of of more
liberal more at ease with modernity
Imams or preachers or movements whatever
in general they just need to combat
inward internally they need to combat
the
Islamism and I think that that makes
sense to me I mean I I grew up you know
in a pretty liberal form of it but a
kind of you know evangelical American
Reagan voting sort of fundamentalist
Christian family but you know really a
much on the liberal side of that really
I mean I don't I wasn't like a Bible
beater or anything but I was associated
I associated with such people and
sometimes you know if you scratched the
surface I had really strange ideas about
about America and about Jesus and
America and like you know America's
destiny and some end time scenario you
know I was raised to believe that at the
end times were nigh and that America was
gonna play this big role in it you know
it's kind of crazy so happen how do you
how do you combat that idea
well you just expose people to less
crazy ideas and hope that those crazy
ideas push out those same ideas push out
the crazy one but beyond that I don't
know obviously security as well I mean
the security services have to protect us
from all forms of
organized violence don't they
hopefully here um well when we can talk
[Music]
well I should have said actually what I
was gonna say is I feel like none of the
topics that we've opened up we got
anywhere near resolving but you gave
some really fascinating insight and I
think what this gives people who are
interested in these topics is an insight
into what you guys talk about yeah we
filed yeah well I blame that on me see
yeah I did my otherwise we could have
solved the whole dosing so up time for a
Nando's anyway that's why just like Isis
our mission is ultimately doomed right I
had a Nando's last week don't worry did
you enjoy it invariably you do enjoy it
but the last question that we always ask
is is we our school I guess is what's
the one thing that we're not talking
about that we really should be talking
about as a society well this has nothing
to do with the Middle East it has to do
with sort of the West I think but I
think what we're not talking about is
how the crisis of liberalism that we're
now experiencing everywhere liberalism
is in crisis
liberals call this the rise of populism
so-called populist call this whatever
they want to call it but liberalism is
is in crisis and what we're not talking
about is the extent to which that is to
do with the the retreat from within our
cultural sphere of of Christianity of
which it seems to be liberalism is a
secular ghost
I think liberalism thought that you
could have all the good things that
Christianity brought with none of the
bad by just stripping Christianity out
of anything supernatural say and then
you have this secular liberal liberalism
but it it's it's incredible IVA love
Christianity or anything but but I find
often when people are debating current
issues and all of the conflicts that are
raging now in our society the the fact
that quite uniquely in human history we
we are excuse me are we are living in
the in the sort of rubble of a vast
religious tradition that we don't know
anything about or really think about
ever I think I often think well maybe it
would be helpful if we knew we would
help if we knew more about it that's a
very good point
and it was something we've talked about
with a couple of previous guests but the
sense though and we're but non-believers
but this just sense that religion is
something that binds people together
into local communities through their
church or whatever institution and more
broadly as an identity kind of like you
talked about with Islamists having an
identity that goes beyond the nation
state or within the nation-state in in
Christian countries the loss of that
doesn't seem to be replaceable or the
loss of meaning doesn't seem to be
replaceable in quite the same way yeah
not the same way it is replaceable other
things bind people together well the
question is what are those things and
are they good they're good I mean
religion wasn't by any means wholly good
either yeah you know cuz it can it could
also bind people together in a bad way
but I'm not actually talking so much
about religions power of binding people
together I think I'm talking about more
about the fact that maybe in this case a
religion like Christianity really might
actually in some weird way be true about
some things that we're not even thinking
about you know we it may address whole
aspects of reality that we don't even
think about we're not encouraged to
think about like what Oh like I mean
like give us one before I mean you know
I am a Christian though a very
idiosyncratic one and so you know like
the concept of like divine grace that
there is animating human beings their
lives
history something like grace that you
can orient yourself towards through
various means usually by like being good
and you can orient yourself away from
but that grace is actually a real thing
an actual thing that is real not
material is a spiritual but it's real
and may cause it may lead to flourishing
and if it's not around you may not
flourish spiritually I mean because
obviously materially my god do we
flourish but I think a lot of people
feel that spiritually we're not
flourishing but then I guess people
don't really believe that spirit spirit
is we have is real that's that's really
what I mean is their spirit is it real
in Russia we have a lot of it thank you
so much for coming on we have been so
busy we haven't had a chance to listen
to all the episodes but I will be going
right now pretty much and listening to
all thank you very much I think it's
gonna be absolutely fascinating it's a
pity we couldn't have Amon here but when
when he's able to leave his security
whatever we'd love to have you both back
on yeah yes yeah I think I think so and
I'll ask him less stupid questions
because I've now been informed by the
word stupid you said they were stupid
it's always me making fun of Francis for
mistakes that he actually made really so
it's all good so I'm happy to take this
one and learn from with this experience
but anyway conflicted absolutely
brilliant podcast check it out guys are
you on Twitter yourself or the pot I am
on Twitter I'm not the most active
Twitter user I actually think Twitter is
pretty stupid so why didn't you tell us
your Twitter handle just in case I think
it's at small farm th om like Thomas at
small farm I think yeah we'll put it in
the video as always follow us on stupid
Twitter Facebook and Instagram ad
trigger pod subscribe to the YouTube
channel remember that this is also
available as a podcast to listen
- as my producers reminding me right now
by just sitting there and as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel as I
said give us an iTunes review if you
enjoy this episode subscribe to us on
patreon or give us money through PayPal
allows us to continue to do the show ups
and also if you've got any ideas of how
to solve voices give us a tweet we'll
see you next week when we turn back
[Music]